[Musique]
et aujourd'hui j'accueille eric coquerel
député la france insoumise de
seine-saint-denis bonjour et comme elle
un bon jour alors nous sommes ensemble
pendant 20 minutes et on va commencer
par parler d'europe puisqu'il hier
emmanuel macron et angela merkel ont
présenté un plan de relance de 500
milliards d'euros pour soutenir en
europe les secteurs et les régions
touchées par cette crise du coc vie de
est-ce que vous saluer ce plan franco
allemand non il est ridiculement bas et
correspond en réalité à des critères de
traiter d'austérité habituelles voilà il
y avait deux solutions de teint j'espère
que la messe n'est pas dite
comme on dit mais il y avait deux
solutions ce que nous proposions
c'est-à-dire faire en sorte que on
annule la dette par un système de dette
perpétuelle cirque la banque centrale
européenne prête aux états directement
pour passer le le la situation
épidémique et que cet argent soit
conservée et s'annule finalement par
l'inflation alors il n'y a pas du tout
qu'il dise on l'a mis sur la table et
j'ai remarqué qu'il ya des gens des
économistes misent économistes libéraux
qui qui qui font de même
et puis une autre solution c'est ce que
va faire l'union européenne c'est à dire
qu'il ya des prêts qui vont être faits
mais ces prêts vont être d'abord
rembourser et remboursé sur des critères
c'est clairement dit qu'ils sont ceux
édictés par la commission qui sont ce
qu'on a subi depuis maintenant des
années sert des politiques d'austérité
des politiques de réformes structurelles
comme ils disent les réformes
structurelles c'est la casse des
retraites c'est la dérégulation du
travail donc en réalité ils recommencent
exactement ce qui a été fait et ce qui
nous a amené à la crise sanitaire et
social qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
alors il ya quand même une nouveauté
c'est qu'il pourrait y avoir une dette
commune européenne une dette mutualisée
entre les états c'est une avancée dans
la construction européenne alors d'abord
une précision c'est que ce prêt est bas
savait que thierry breton le commissaire
frantz estimé qu'il fallait 1600
milliards
il ya une résolution du parlement
européen qu'il estimait à 2 8 milliards
là c'est 500 milliards et la dette sera
pas vraiment mutualisera d'avant on sait
pas très bien qu'on va être fait parce
que moi je ne goûte pas cette europe qui
avance par le couple soit disant franco
allemand ou henry tcma merkel très
souvent qui qui a dit que le cap
et qu'il impose à tout le monde il faut
déjà attendre de savoir comment ça se
passait il ya des pays du nord par
exemple ne sont pas d'accord même avec
la manière dont dans les choses se font
et deuxièmement cette mutualisation elle
va être mutualisés mais justement sur
des conditions c'est-à-dire que chaque
pays va bénéficier d'argent selon ses
besoins certes mais la manière de
rembourser d'ailleurs n'est pas défini
clairement et encore une fois elle va se
faire sur des critères qui vont
étrangler les pays en question
donc là on ne sort pas en réalité des
politiques qui par exemple ont fait ont
étranglé la grèce pendant des années des
années si ce n'est c'est la seule
différence ça c'est vrai que à priori là
cette fois ci la banque centrale
européenne prêterait directement aux
états c'est la différence elle est
importante certes mais par contre elle
ne jure elle ne elle n'est pas suffisant
pour équilibrer la petitesse des prêts
et les critères sur lesquels ils vont
être remboursés cela ne vous suffit pas
alors hier emmanuel macron et angela
merkel ont montré leur volonté de créer
une europe de la santé pour produire des
masques des tests des médicaments est-ce
que c'est à l'europe d'avoir cette
compétence en matière de santé coûte et
déjà ça serait bien que la france allait
là parce que la situation que nous avons
connue
c'est un pays qui a été incapable de
faire face à la crise sanitaire
pas de masque pas de test pas assez de
l'ide respiratoires et cdd des choses
qui manquaient de partout de par l'ape
des politiques de délocalisation vous
savez comme moi que par exemple on a en
2018 fermer le plus gros producteur de
masques en france qui était en bretagne
pour faire en sorte délocaliser d'abord
en chine et après en tunisie et ses
exemples là je pourrais vous en donnez
plaindre qu'il faut revenir à une
souveraineté sanitaire au niveau
français pour koné vous français parce
que force est de constater que ce qui
vient de se passer au niveau
l'européenne
les frontières se sont fermées et chaque
pays finalement agi avec ses propres
moyens
il n'y a pas eu il n'y a pas eu une
union européenne une solidarité qui
s'est établie c'est pas les 200 lits qui
ont été ouverts en allemagne pour
quelques pays autour qui qui est à la
hauteur de ce qu'il aurait fallu faire
donc moi je rêve déjà rassuré sur le
fait que nous ayons nous on souveraineté
sanitaire en france une souveraineté des
médicaments et si après au port des
coopérations aller
l'européenne tant mieux mais ne
repartons pas dans la situation que nous
venons de vivre pour les années à venir
donc vous êtes plutôt pour une
souveraineté nationale en matière de
santé je suis déjà pour faire en sorte
que nous ne vivions pas la situation est
la même situation
ça a été des pays chacun les uns et les
autres confrontés de manière différente
à la crise et avec des moyens qui ont
manqué à certains parce que les usines
ont fermé de masques de respirateurs
qu'on n'a pas que le gouvernement
français ça c'est sa responsabilité n'a
pas assez anticipé en matière de tests
regardez l'allemagne a anticipé que je
sache il n'y a pas eu une coopération
entre l'allemagne et la france de ce
point de vue là on a reçu plus de
masques de la chine et plus d'aces de la
chine que l'allemagne et ça a été la
même chose pour l'italie
donc moi je suis très méfiant sur ses
discours comme ça très très angélique et
puis quand il ya la réalité du terrain
il ya tous les égoïsmes nationaux se
sont réveillés jeanne jeu je pense que
de ce point de vue là on doit absolument
faire en sorte que la prochaine crise
parce qu'on aura d'autres nous soyons
capables de l'affronter avec une
souveraineté sanitaires alors dans ce
plan de relance européenne il y aura
aussi une dimension écologique avec la
fixation d'un prix minimum du carbone au
niveau européen est ce que vous croyez à
cette europe verte cette europe
écologique déjà ce que je remarque c'est
que dans le plan de relance on parle
déjà de roland c'est à dire qu'on repart
sur l'idée de croissance sans définir
qu'est-ce qui doit croître qu'est ce
qu'il voit décroître par exemple sans
définir le fait que l' on vient d'avoir
un moment est extrêmement douloureux
mais qui a eu qu'un avantage c'est que
vous avez vu que les taux de co2 ont
beaucoup baissé il ya eu beaucoup moins
de d'activité comment on fait en sorte
d'éviter la prochaine grande crise
environnementale qui va venir il ya
aucune réflexion là dessus et donc la
seule manière dont on envisage
aujourd'hui l'écologie
en europe c'est le capitalisme vert
c'est un grand marché vers nous on ne
voit pas comme ça nous on pense que
c'est les états qui doivent planifier
une politique
évidemment ça ne veut pas dire de tout
nationaliser ils ont le marché peut
continuer les entreprises vous
continuerez à exister mais y ait au
moins un cap qui est donnée par les
états et pourquoi pas au niveau européen
par contre avec j'allais dire le fait de
tourner l'économie sur - - - polluées
sur le fait de relocaliser et c'est ce
que je vous ai dit précédemment
bon là c'est parce qu'ils
alors taxe carbone aux frontières très
bien nous ça fait longtemps qu'on
propose du protectionnisme solidaire
mais encore une fois si on n'est pas
capable de le faire à l'échelle
européenne fera au moins le faire à
l'échelle française c'est à dire que on
arrête d'importer des produits souvent
produit par des sociétés qui ont les
mêmes actionnaires simplement qu'on
délocalise et ailleurs pour profiter de
prix du travail plus bas et qui apporte
avec des coûts sociaux et écologiques
évidemment beaucoup plus bas ça il faut
arrêter cette politique du grand
déménagement du monde qui nous a emmené
la catastrophe qu'on vient de vivre
alors cela fait une semaine que la
france se dé confine quel premier bilan
faites-vous de ce déconfinement alors
qu'il ya déjà des foyers épidémiques qui
émergent en france notamment à orléans
dans un abattoir
très sincèrement j'espère que le virus
est saisonnier voilà mon espoir on a on
a parlé de nous france a soumises de
déconfinement hasardeuse parce que en
réalité mail macro et fixer une date et
après il a fallu que le gouvernement
s'adapte par exemple on avait dit faut
sept cent mille tests gouvernance et d 1
million 700 mille neuf cents par semaine
cet angle fermé c'était la condition
pour des confiné nous at on dit mais
cette formule 1 lassé le conseil
scientifique avait dit ça aujourd'hui on
en est si vous suivez roncq il dit
lui-même
on en est pas à 50 milles par jour donc
on a des conditions dans lesquelles ces
faits le déconfinement qui ne sont
vraiment pas optimum en termes de tests
en termes de masse pour parce que les
masses doit être gratuit que quand on
demande à des gens d'aller travailler le
matin ils prennent dans les transports
en commun de va pas risquer une amende
de 135 euros ils doivent risquer le fait
qu'on leur donne un masque gratuit ça
doit être ça la chose qui doit être
proposée et puis dans les transports ça
pas non plus qui conquit franciliens
c'est que toutes les lignes de transport
qui viennent notamment du nord parisien
se faire la halle où les gens n'ont pas
télétravail c'est ça vraiment pas été
terrible donc moi je suis inquiet sur la
situation voilà sur une possible
deuxième vague et beaucoup des pistes et
wolof l'a prévu en juillet c'est pour ça
que je vous dis j'espère que le virus
est saisonnier parce que c'est parce que
je souhaite à mon pays alors dans ce
déconfinement faut-il rouvrir les lieux
de culte je rappelle qu'hier le conseil
d'état a sommé le gouvernement de
rouvrir les lieux de culte au nom je
cite de la liberté religieuse quelle est
votre position sur ce sur les lieux de
culte ont jamais été fermé
c'est la question à 100 dans les valises
du rassemblement les cultes bon j'ai pas
lu le
ce qu'a écrit le conseil est à moi je
suis étonné qu'on ne parle dans ces cas
là que des lieux de culte parce que ça
serait quand même assez étonnant qu'on
autorise des rassemblements dans les
lieux de culte par contre on ne
s'autorise pas des rassemblements
politiques ou des rassemblements
culturels il faut que je veux dire bon
donc moi je sais que j'ai tendance à
considérer que si on pense aujourd'hui
que des rassemblements dans des lieux
confinés reste dangereux vis-à-vis de
l'épidémie
que ce soit les cultes ou autre il faut
les il faut continuer les limites et je
vous rappelle quand même que c'est un
moment d'un rassemblement d'un culte à
mulhouse que s'est développé un des
grands clusters en france donc voilà
faisons attention je vais lire le en
détail mais ça ne peut pas être juste
les rassemblements des cultes y soit
autorisé chacun de comprendre donc pour
vous le gouvernement devrait passer
outre cette décision du conseil d'état
s'il juge que d'un point de vue
sanitaire
et d'un point de vue d'égalité j'allais
dire entre les différentes formes de
rassemblement sanaa ça pose problème oui
encore une fois il faut que je lise le
ski a écrit exactement au conseil d'état
ce que je n'ai pas faites et puis il ya
une autre question qui se pose cependant
ce déconfinement faut-il organiser le
second tour des élections municipales au
mois de juin
on va connaître normalement aujourd'hui
l'avis du conseil scientifique vous
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
s'il ya le moindre risque sanitaire faut
pas le faire voilà d'abord parce que
c'est pas juste le deuxième tour on peut
pas imaginer un deuxième tour sans
campagne
la démocratie c'est aussi la campagne
donc ça veut dire par exemple qu'on sera
dans un moment où tous les
rassemblements les réunions seront
autorisés au delà 10 personnes c'est ça
que ça veut dire si c'est pas le cas si
on pense qu'il ya un risque épidémique
non il faut pas qu'ils aient lieu on va
pas recommencer ce qui s'est passé au
premier tour moi j'ai vu des militants
des élus
être malade certains très malade
certains malheureusement même
disparaître des gens que je connais
quelques jours après les municipales
et contrairement à ce que 10 mm macro le
premier c'est évidemment dans les
derniers jours des municipales le jour
de la campagne qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
quant à eux été contaminés donc ne
recommençons pas pas un seul risque
voilà pour moi la ligne de conduite
si on pense que c'est le cas ça pourrait
se faire si c'est pas le cas il faut
refaire les élections plus tard et puis
si le conseil scientifique donne un avis
positif comment fait-on campagne
électorale en cette période
justement ça ne peut pas être on peut
pas imaginer que ce soit une campagne
riquiqui voilà il ya déjà le premier
tour a déjà été largement faussé il ya
beaucoup de gens qui se sont abstenus il
n'avait pas tort parce qu'ils avaient la
trouille d'aller de contaminer donc on
va pas recommencer
soit c'est un une élection qui peut se
rendre et conditions normales
démocratique avec des réunions de fond
tout ce qu'il ya dedans d'une dans une
campagne électorale soit sinon il sera
beaucoup plus raisonnable de prolonger
les conseils municipaux qui qui qui
précédent jusqu'à avoir des conditions
normales de démocratie donc selon vous
il pourrait y avoir un scrutin des
municipales insincère en cette période
abbassi si on peut pas faire campagne et
qu'on est dans des situations où encore
une fois c'est c1 déconfinement partiel
les gens peuvent pas se réunir bien sûr
alors déjà ça n'a pas été très sympa
était sincère au premier tour des
municipales en mars au moins qu'on
recommence pas cette fois ci la même
erreur on va parler des questions
sociales et notamment de notre système
de santé puisque le gouvernement prépare
un plan en faveur de l'hôpital avec des
hausses de salaires une amélioration des
carrières pour le personnel des
investissements également dans le
matériel hospitalier est ce que vous
saluer ce plan hôpital pas déjà il faut
l avoir exactement dans le détail de ce
qu'a dit monsieur vérone en gilet je
suis un peu inquiet parce que
manifestement il des choses qu'il n'a
pas compris
alors il comprend certaines choses il
dit que en gros il donne raison aux
soignants qui depuis deux ans réclame
d'être mieux payés d'être plus et
d'avoir des moyens notamment réouverture
de lit je note une chose c'est que s'il
avait eu ça depuis deux ans si
gouvernant les a bien entendu il ne se
serait peut-être pas il dort pas été
confrontées à l'épidémie
sans moyens pas assez pas assez payés
passé de lit je rappelle qu'il ya
quarante mille soignants qui ont été
contaminés c'était les premiers
victime de cette impréparation donc
gouvernement finisse par en tant qu' on
va pas seulement satisfaire de primes
dont je rappelle en plus que l son
différentiel selon les soignants que
vous soyez l'hôpital selon que vous
soyez dans les ehpad et autres donc
qu'ils disent il faut des salaires tant
mieux moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est quand
il dit comment c'est à dire il faut
augmentation des salaires
mais on va parler de la semaine des 35
heures d'aménagement du temps de travail
il ose parler j'ai entendu le terme
monter des compétences excusez moi j'ai
pas l'impression qu'il eut aprem de
compétences chez les soignants qui ont
été face au corona bio et son contraire
je pense que c'est grâce à ça quand ils
ont tenu malgré tout et parfois je lui
dis alors dépend donc il peut pas dire
de conditions et en un autre terme qui
m'a inquiété c'est le fait qu'il a dit
il faudra faire des choix
alors général qu on dit qu'il faut faire
des choix ça veut dire qu'on prend dans
d'autres services publics d'autres
dépenses publiques
ou alors qu'on fait des choix interne à
la santé publique ça c'est pas possible
voilà s'il ya des choix à faire li sf
coûte à l'état la suppression 3,6
milliards c'est à peu près l'équivalent
du plan hôpital d'après les syndicats et
les collectifs
on a l'argent tout trouvé autre question
sociale sur l'avenir dans les
entreprises est ce que vous craignez une
vague de licenciements massifs
à la sortie de cette crise sanitaire
bien sûr c'est pour ça que nous étions
et nous sommes toujours pour interdire
les licenciements de toute entreprise
qui a reçu des aides de l'état
voilà et après de voir comment pour
certaines entreprises sur des critères
pas comme le fait le gouvernement pas
sans critères mais sur des critères
sociaux et écologiques on peut aider ces
entreprises à passer le cap
mais je pense que ça aurait été
raisonnable tout comme d'ailleurs pour
une fois voyez je suis d'accord être le
patron du medef quand il explique qu'on
aurait pu attendre fin juin pour réviser
et pour affaiblir le système du chômage
partiel comme il va l'être fait début
juin voilà je pense que il faut tout
faire pour garder de l'emploi mais ça
peut pas se faire par des prêts ou des
datations entreprises sans critères
comme le gouvernement le fait ça c'est
une politique qui a qui a été
catastrophique ces dernières années
finalement ce système du chômage partiel
pendant cette crise sanitaire mis enfin
déployés par le gouvernement
ce chômage partiel il a bien marché pour
sauver l'économie grecque comme quoi
heureusement qu'il nous reste quelques
lois sociales pour lesquelles le
gouvernement a pu s'appuyer parce que le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'il a il
en a cassé d'autres par exemple les
chsct vous savez c'est lé comité qui
travaille sur laquelle sont l'hygiène et
la santé dans les entreprises
je vous rappelle qu'il l'a supprimée
avec la loi pénicaud dans les quelques
entreprises sa subtilité subsister
malgré tout je pensais à la sncf
ça a été très pratique au début du
confinement pour permettre aux agents
justement d'être de mieux se protéger
donc heureusement il n'a pas tout casser
le cheval car si il l'avait pas encore
fait et ça a bien aidés dans la période
tant mieux et justement sur le front
social en terme de combats sociaux dans
la période compliquée qui arrive où il
va falloir reconstruire le pays est ce
que vous prenez un retour dans la rue si
le gouvernement continue à s'engager
comme dans ce qu'il a fait que les
ordonnances de sa première loi urgent
c'est à dire premières mesures on
dérégule le temps de travail on prend
des jours de congé aux gens qu'ils qui
ont été victimes de du confinement
je pense que les gens là ne mettront pas
s'ils continuent à laisser la répression
s'installer là je vous parle la sncf
il ya des cheminots ils ont été en
première ligne des cheminots tout le
monde a dit heureusement qu'ils étaient
là
heureusement qu'ils avaient une
compagnie nationale qui dépend encore
ouvertes à la concurrence pour assurer
le transport le j'allais dire des
dispositions stratégiques liées au
transport
il ya de certain c'est cheminots quiris
par le licenciement aujourd'hui pour
fait grève je pense à eric bezou je
pense à monsieur sharifi qui cégétiste
paris est bon et on veut les radiers je
pense que la première mesure à faire ça
serait justement de comprendre qu'il
faut une amnistie social et qu'il faut
pas avoir un esprit de revanche parce
que sinon je pense effectivement ça va
vite repartir et ça va vite se
remobiliser les gens sont en colère ils
sont en colère notamment parce que le
gouvernement a quand même largement
failli dans l'âge de l'anticipation et
la gestion de cette crise donc je serai
je je je prendrai des décisions qui
seraient au moins de ne pas punir les
syndicalistes qui sont mobilisés pour
saïd public précédemment eric coquerel
on va maintenant ouvrir une page
politique et parler de l'avenir de la
gauche dans cette france d'après le
coronavirus puisque beaucoup de partis
de gauche et les écologistes proposent
une union de la gauche alors il ya
beaucoup de parties les socialistes les
communistes générations et les
communistes
monsieur roussel ian brossât a par
exemple signé c'est facile roussel quel
dirigeant du parti haq a retiré sa
signature d'accords alors il ya
peut-être une division au sein des
communistes mais en tout cas beaucoup de
monde à gauche prônent cette union de la
gauche et des écologistes pour
reconstruire le pays
l'un des grands absents de cette union
c'est la france insoumise pour quelles
raisons la des genres nous l'a pas
demandée ont bien raison voilà c'est ça
a été ça a été évident et on ne l'a pas
demandée on n'a pas demandé me prends
goût sinon à monsieur besancenot
il ya des gens qui osent demander
d'autres gens à qui on demande pas donc
manifestement certains avaient avais pas
envie de s'embarrasser de ce que nous
représentons pour c'est dommage parce
que sept millions d'électeurs et le
poids que nous avons c'est pas mal mais
au-delà de ça au delà de cette question
d'abord je reviens là dessus il ya cent
cinquante signataires mais non il ya des
partis qui s'engage pas mais vous
remarquerez par europe écologie monsieur
bayrou ne signe pas il avait mis sa
signature il l'enlever yannick jadot
oui d'accord mais ça veut dire que les
choses ne sont pas si simples c'est pas
comme vous avez le temps ça le montrer
europe ecologie le pc le ps il ya tout à
côté non c'est plus compliqué que ça
deuxièmement cet appel moi j'ai regardé
bon c'est bien c'est bien la faire des
appels unités en jalles et diront on en
ignorant certains dès le départ mais en
plus de ça quand vous cherchez des
compromis entre des gens qui ne sont pas
forcément d'accord vous arriver à des
consensus et vous regardez le centralité
du consensus et le les consensus trouvé
n'aborde aucune mesure concrète qui
peuvent fâcher par exemple avec des
socialistes qui n'ont pas encore soldé
les comptes des années hollande
donc c'est un texte qui est quand même
très très faible très insipide j'allais
dire et qui ne peut pas faire là dessus
qu'on peut bâtir des choses maintenant
ils font ça très bien il avance nous on
préfère ce qui va se passer demain soir
c'est à dire à l'appel de 18
organisations syndicales papa les
moindres solidaires fsu cgt des
associations comme attac oxfam les amis
de la terre je vais pas tous les citer
ceux ci appellent des organisions
politique a discuté ensemble dans ce qui
pour nous est plus proche de la
fédération populaire qu'on appelle de
nos voeux voyez on y sera et
on y sera même avec plaisir et avec un
esprit constructif ça ça me semble bien
plus porteur pour l'avenir alors vous
parliez des mesures concrètes pour
reconstruire le pays
effectivement dans cette tribune pour
une union de la gauche il y à quelques
mesures concrètes et justement j'ai
choisi quelques mesures phares
regardez on va aller voir sur cette
infographie vous allez me dire ce que
vous en pensez
retour de l impôt sur la fortune la
création d'une taxe carbone sociale
c'est-à-dire pour redistribuer également
en faveur des plus vulnérables
une création d'une nouvelle protection
sociale avec un revenu digne pour tous
et enfin des nationalisations
stratégique
est ce que vous êtes favorable 7 à ses
côtés alors là vous citer le texte
la plupart de ces mesures dans le texte
il est indiqué il faut tendre vers faut
aller vers donc on sait pas jusqu'où et
moi je me rappelle quand même de
hollande qui avait 10 nickel la finance
les et son ennemi puis on a vu après les
choses concrètes prenons pas remplies
nationalisation stratégique
moi j'aimerais savoir ce qu'on entend
concrètement est ce qu'on dit d'accord
par exemple pour dire que la sncf doit
redevenir une entreprise 100% public
sans ouverture à la concurrence
c'est une chose très concrètes est ce
qu'on est d'accord que air france doit
être nationalisées voyez moi je préfère
des choses parce qu'en général c'est là
dessus qu'il ya eu des déserts des
accords dans les années passées
notamment avec le parti socialiste
de la même manière de nouvelles
protections sociales revenu dix mois la
protection sociale telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui me va je pense qu'il faut la
renforcer
mais je suis toujours pour une
protection sociale assise sur les
cotisations liées au travail tel que
c'est avec une mécanisme de solidarité
entre les travailleurs et là dessus je
ne sais pas ce qui est indiqué donc
c'est quand vous lisez attentivement
texte vous avez des beaucoup de voeux
pieux et dans les mesures concrètes vous
avez peu de choses parme sur l'europe
là vous n'avez pas mis l'europe serait
très intéressant parce que là
manifestement sur l'europe on reste dans
le texte sur j'allais dire le schéma
finalement de d améliorer un peu la
situation l'union européenne qui ne va
pas du tout aujourd'hui parce qu'elle
est conne basée avant tout sur une
politique d'austérité
bon il ya tout un ensemble de choses
donc pour vous dire ce texte très bien
si les gens peuvent le signe ensemble
très bien s'ils peuvent s'accorder sur
les mesures mais je ne crois pas nous on
porte lanières en commun par un
programme qui a eu quand même 7 millions
de voix convient de retravailler qu'on a
remis sur la table
je pense que
pour le coup il ya plus de mesures
concrètes et j'invite les forces qui
veulent à venir en discuter avec nous
ces deux programmes
mais alors pour conclure est ce que la
porte de la france insoumise est
complètement fermée à cette union de la
gauche mais ça c'est pas d'abord ce
n'est pas l'union de la gauche ne vous
le dire vous avez peut-être pas compris
c'est pas l'union de la gauche en plus
sur la gauche type ce qui s'est passé
dans le passé on remet un parti
socialiste au centre de tout alors
qu'ils ne pèsent plus que 6% des voix et
qu'il a longtemps été par sa force un
peu une hypothèque du vote utile sur une
voie qui a entraîné la gauche à la
catastrophe qu'on sait et à monsieur
macron donc cette union de l'an de la
gauche là non si on parle de
rassemblement je lui dis nous nous
sommes favorables un rassemblement qui
permet une application citoyenne
populaire massive et ça ça passe très
certainement pas rouvrir les frontières
oui avec des forces de politique mais on
discute avec elle vous savez on n'a
jamais on n'a jamais arrêté ce qu avec
le parti communiste où on n'a jamais
arrêté discuter même si parfois avec
plus compliqué avec europe écologie mais
c'est vrai que ça nous intéresse aussi
vu l'urgence de la situation de travail
et les syndicats les associations dans
un espèce de nouveaux fronts pillay
front populaire en 36 on pense souvent
au gouvernement mais il y avait le front
populaire qui réunissait aussi justement
des forces politiques des collectifs
citoyens des associations des syndicats
nous c'est un peu poussé ce qu'on
souhaite pour essayer de trouver un
nouvel espoir voilà on est plus
fédération populaire cugnaux de la
gauche en amont rapidement sur
l'assemblée nationale eric coquerel et
la majorité absolue qui est perdu par le
groupe la république en marche
qu'est ce que vous en pensez je pense
que ça reflète le fait que monsieur
makonda vraiment plus majorité dans le
pays
je pense qu'il l'avait déjà pas mais là
maintenant ça se traduit compris à
l'assemblée et à dire c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour nous là il a plus la
majorité sol moi j'ai tendance à penser
que tout ça devrait être concrétisée
dans les urnes
voilà je ne crois pas monsieur macron
dit lui-même que son prague finalement
il est caduc
il dit qu'il faut le monde d'après qui
s'est trompé il faut se réinventer il a
plus de majorité
maintenant ces cas là c'est le retour au
pop c'est pour ça que moi j'ai avancé
l'idée de dissolution je pense ça serait
une bien meilleure solution
dès que les conditions sanitaires le
permettent de redonner le pouvoir au
peuple pour redéfinir un nouveau mandat
et une nouvelle majorité
une dissolution et après la gauche
plurielle au pouvoir et nous avons en
tout cas nous les capacités françaises
soumises de gouverner avec un programme
tous ceux qui pourraient se retrouver
sur la proa dont je rappelle qu'en
réalité c'est pas le problème de france
insoumise un pouvoir bien connu les
histoires de de plus des années de
difficultés au programme c'est un
programme qui datent même du traité
conseil européen en 2005 qui sait qui
c'est qui c'est qui s'est fait au fur et
à mesure je pense que ça pourrait être
une bonne batterie commune pour
gouverner parce qu'il soit
merci beaucoup eric coquerel d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et d'avoir été
avec nous en plateau ce matin